now I was lucky I had it's only good
teachers is so important my cousin try
to do a human GUI people understood
maths as much as you know like for music
as an example like no one has to push
anyone become a musician because it
sells itself it's a it's a natural sort
of thing yeah you seem to just click
with it yeah and also it's also there's
there's lots of different ways there's
lots of access how you could do you
could be a 3-quart punk band or you go
and do Cheney music so there's lots of
different and also there's the emotion
involved so it actually expresses
emotion but for mathematics I mean the
idea that there's no emotion it matters
is ridiculous because the struggle you
have to go through to get to an answer
you mean you have to there'll be some
investors unit yeah and then when you do
arrive your solution that's why there's
that payoff that that's right yeah yeah
yeah that's right yeah yeah so use
someone who is able to struggle with a
problem oh it's kind of funny I mean I
think when I was at school I was I was
the struggler yes I think it's whether
you want to struggle but you were happy
to struggle yeah absolutely really which
is kind of how I ended up where I am
that's right so that's that's what makes
the difference is is the is the ability
to struggle and it's like I can only
really explain it to analogy where where
if I try even know if I handed you a
guitar you know and and I got you to
learn these scales you know and you'd
never heard you'd never heard before and
it's hurting your fingers if you ever
played like you know you're not talking
about pop starving yeah yeah yeah you'll
get cramped and it's like why am I doing
this for but if instead you hear a song
and it speaks to you something speaks to
you someones written a song and it's
like that's how I feel and and and for
some people it's like I want to play
that song that'll be what motivates us
what motivates you and so then you've
got someone working to try and try and
make this happen well now it has a
purpose has now all of that pain in that
struggle is it snowing somewhere that's
rather them because because someone
someone's telling me that's right yeah
and so now with maths what happens with
math is that you have these you have
these wings so for me you know i was
lucky i had i had some really good
teachers and it's
important the person the GUI the human
GUI you know it's actually having
someone there who can kind of help and
guide that's kind of the person through
whom you experience math that's right
now doing yourself yeah yeah yeah that's
right you're very incredibly important
super important right and so yeah I had
teachers that would guide me through
doing a math problem and when you get it
when you clicks when it clicks there is
this again it's like the drug thing this
is rush I actually have a feeling it's
like my hair stands i'll back on my head
that's hard for me it's like it's like I
destination is they get this you do you
get the sensation and and it is amazing
because it's like you're in darkness and
suddenly it's lit but it's abstract it's
different to walking it's different to
the world that we know like the the
patterns and structures are like you
can't see them necessarily but you kind
of because they're so intricate and kind
of they loop around and and they are
onto itself but once you start to
understand well once you actually
understand that you go you have improved
this when someone gives you another
problem and if you don't know the answer
that becomes a motivation that becomes
the motivation it's like someone's given
me this problem or there's a problem
that no one can solve and it's like why
can't nobody solvers what's the reason
and in this units because there's a lack
of knowledge or there's a you know
people don't know the right approach and
so there's this wonderful thing of like
the mystery and the end the the
challenge to be able to solve these
things and that's what motivates
mathematicians that's one that's why you
know maths is fun that idea which should
never say is that's like it's a quick
way to get ignored like that's a quick
way to go that's the kind of person or a
Z because it's it's it's uh it's not fun
it's like it is it is a serious charge
well it's a challenge but the but it's
more than fun it's passion it's like you
know you want to do anything in life
that you're really that you really want
there's more stuff going on
it's like it's almost like I can do this
and I've had that feeling and there's
another level and if I get that level
it'll be amazing and then think of where
you can go from there yeah and it's just
like and that's that's the killer the
killer is that you get to something new
you see new vistas beyond that or you
see new patterns just recently I was
thinking about rethinking about
something I haven't thought about since
I was a kid and it was it was a problem
i set myself that I was trying to work
out if it was possible to trap light
with curves so I had this idea it
bounces around with in there ya know
what my idea was that I had these two
curves right and and I was looking about
tangents and I thought about if a light
a light ray comes in this is all
theoretical because you know you're
constricted by nature and atoms and
machining but if a light beam comes in
is it possible to like have it bounce up
and down up and down up and down up and
down until you actually have it
approaching this limit where it's going
up and down back and forth and it's
never going to escape out of there yeah
and so and so I was trying to work out
the equations cattle were for how you
would make those curved in such a way
yeah okay and I remember struggling with
that in year nine and I just left it but
I rethought about that recently and I
thought that's an interesting problem
and and i was wondering now like i have
to staff that i'm actually the opposite
i have to stop myself from starting to
do math problems because i get obsessed
he I spent 12 months on one math problem
and when I finally solved if I crimes
that means that follow but um what was
the problem by the way curiously uh it
was too it was to show as a math
Olympics problem but it was a short
listed problem so actually didn't even
make it to the final paper but it was
still uncut yeah it was still really
hard it was it was show that any
rational number a fraction to any
fraction can be expressed as the sum of
two cubes over the sum of two cubes so a
cube plus B cube and cq50 cubed you can
express any fraction and so fractions
you think of them individual okay yes
yes so instead of like
it's a good example so instead of 406
213 ok so that's the idea so it's like
two and three can that be expressed as
the sum of the cube sum of two cubes
over the sum of two cubes and it's like
how the theory that it always can be is
that there that's what you have to prove
yeah okay yeah you have to prove how
come how that can be and and the and you
know this when you're doing a math
Olympics problem like they are so
they're so amazing because they really
are I mean it's almost like if you're
too good at doing maths at school in the
sense that you've learned how to do a
specific way you've marked Eversole of a
process is an algorithm yeah good at
that yeah and that without they actually
kind of late though that will support
you like there's no like you can't you
can't do it you can't actually solve
these problems the way that you've been
taught you need to be able to think of
it where you haven't been taught yet
yeah yeah so you've got to really play
around and and the way that problem is
is eventually solved is that you you
pick certain numbers you kind of have
you know you have like n plus and plus
em and take em and when you when you
expand these things out things will
cancel and you can factorize and so the
I once you once you kind of cotton on
that you need to factorize things out so
you're taking up these like elements you
end up with like and on em fields and so
you can get to and yeah and yeah but
that but the trick is is that you have n
on em which is great but then you have
these other sort of functions and and
it's like those functions why cancel
necessarily and the and agenda the
insight which only came from solving
another problem was this was the sort of
function i needed a sort of sort of
equation i needed was one that's called
symmetric so a symmetric equation is one
that if you flip the variables it looks
the same it's so it's like x x squared
okay so example x squared plus XY plus
2y squared okay oh ok flip x and y yep
we'll have y squared plus YX + yeah ok I
so it's like it's not benefit if it goes
if it was x squared plus y squared
if we flip it it's y squared plus x
squared is the same all good yeah okay
and so that's what I realized was like I
had to try and find a way to do it and
but with that in with that idea in mind
you have to kind of go through this
gnarly kind of algebra and then it ends
up being something quite simple hey it's
like trying to find that hidden door in
a game and trying to push all the doors
it should marry on everything yeah it's
this way you have to hold the spacebar
you know and you have to do something
special it was it was just just amazing
the the problem itself was amazing
because it was like it was like we know
that you can do algebra and you're going
to have to do some pretty fancy algebra
but it's the idea is quite simple the
idea of that having a symmetric function
that cancel and then symmetric functions
have all these repercussions and physics
and there's this this is emmy note any
notes and she was like the kind of the
most prominent female physicists like of
20th century and she she did this
amazing work in physics where she found
that she found symmetries in nature were
linked directly linked to conserved
quantities so she found that the fact
that that physics is the same at any
time so there isn't a specific time
london time is you know is you can you
can do anything at any time and the
physics won't change that related to I
think conservation of energy and it
ended your idea of space the things that
you can do anything in any particular
space in it doesn't matter we're not
talking about that curvature of space is
like physically being one point of the
other that meant that meant conservation
in momentum I don't I don't know if
that's exactly right I haven't looked at
the stuff in ages but it's just the idea
that someone found a link between
symmetry which a cemetery means or
something repeatable so you can repeat
physics anywhere and it should work the
same like the physics that works on
earth should work on the other side of
the universe it shouldn't be different
it's not like you're gonna pass some
threshold and that we got new laws here
yeah yeah exactly such like here's a
fence and there's different roles in the
video you passed into it you know you've
got you going to Queensland to my
an hour behind as like huh or in front
or whatever but anyway so yeah so it was
this it was his beautiful kind of things
and it was and it came down to these
symmetries and the symmetries I could
see in the equations and so I was like
ah there's not enough time I'm going to
do all the math so going to try to
understand this stuff and see this this
is the thing that motivates you is like
is that once you get a taste for it you
get a taste for all this awesomeness
that's out there you really feel
compelled to see something that no one's
ever seen or in my case understand stuff
and then I have the great privilege and
excitement to try and explain it to
people yeah so that's that's where it
all comes from so it is it is really
it's a it's a serious it's a serious
thing I'm very very lucky I think to
have been able to leave and left my job
because I was working as a statistician
in the wine industry and and I was able
to leave my job to do this because there
was a need for it hmm so I'm very very
very fortunate because it's given me
time to focus and get better